they call this place mid spare Jericho
Hebrew for overlooking Jericho and it
does with quite a view to it is an
Israeli settlement on top of the hill
with the Palestinian town of Jericho in
the valley below
behind the fence in the leafy streets
the Israeli Jews who live here feel safe
it is after all they believe their home
politically legally historically weird
living in a in a settlement that is kind
of marooned with with people who you
don't get on with all around you it is
it's different than like you know when I
used to live in America ar e pili Chau
ski moved here six years ago from
America ancestrally for him
he came home and to have his presence
here in this settlement be viewed as
legal by Donald Trump well it is a big
moment it's great it's great news my
reaction is nothing less than
celebratory and full gratitude to the
Trump administration why is that it's
establishing facts facts that we've
known facts that are clear and obvious
and now it's on the record
and we can move forward with these facts
having been established the settlement
has been here since the 70s and they're
still expanding on land that under
international law they are occupying
illegally at least that's how most
countries interpret it it's a short
drive through the gate of the settlement
and out down through the Jordan Valley
to another world
Palestine is what the Arab people here
in the West Bank would like this land to
be officially a state a country Jericho
is one of the oldest inhabited cities in
the world and yet still like everywhere
here the argument persists who was here
first
Nadia Chaka Khan II has lived here 40
years his restaurant is just off the
main square Bill Clinton the bride there
brother the forum President Barack Obama
the foreigners and they all said this is
medicine and then so what makes only
Donald Trump say this is an Israeli land
I mean one person after the whole world
who for example your arguments but what
do you believe nobody really wants me on
the edge of Jericho is a symbol of
Palestinian hope that they will one day
return
to the land back up the hill and beyond
but someone else is there now who was
there first
the peace process a solution of two
states Israel and Palestine it is far
off mark stone Sky News in the West Bank